each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
research university relations and as a
continuing part our series of software
engineering and on behalf of bantling
John Devon open schulte like to welcome
professor very vain as a guest lecturer
for today it's impossible to
truly do justice and recognizing various
accomplishments Phyllis software
engineering as a major contributor to
our government country and society in
this important field his contributions
awards are really too too numerous to
list so with that Microsoft is pleased
to welcome Perry game trw professor of
software engineering and the director
for the center of software engineering
intimacy thanks John it's a pleasure be
here and I would like to thank you and
Microsoft for your co-sponsorship of our
USC Center for software engineering
affiliates program that basically we
have a couple of meetings every year
where we get together with the
affiliates and address a number of
research issues that we're doing and try
to get feedback from the affiliate
companies which include most of the
major computing companies and some of
the telecom companies and aerospace
companies in the line the one that we're
doing next March fifteenth through 18th
is on model driven development and so if
any of you are interested in that like
to welcome you to come down and
participate in it so it's it's also a
pleasure to come and talk about the
economics of software dependability to
an organization that I think has really
probably the biggest stake in the world
and in trying to achieve dependability
economically most organizations don't
have as much invested in soft words you
do most organizations basically have
control over most of the parameters that
determine their dependability but what I
found it is that in a lot of cases the
the sources of dependability challenges
that you have or all these third-party
device drivers and people hanging
software having different assumptions to
a lot of your infrastructure software we
have a group where a tool called easy
win win that helps p stakeholders
negotiate when win requirements up and
it runs on windows and we go out and
demo it around the world in different
places and in a lot of cases it crashes
and people pointed windows and say why
is this crashing but for example in
England they they had this very high
definition display and it was
communicating with windows by more or
less saying i am 25 different displays
and totally confusing the operating
system about what was going on on these
25 different displays open so again I
appreciate the kind of challenges you
have here in trying to achieve
dependability and trying to do it in a
in a cost-effective way oh he'll get
these things
so uh yeah what we'll talk about is you
know what is the business case for
software dependability and I'll give an
example and see now what what the
business case is for various kinds of
test tools and things like that and then
I go through a number of examples of
situations where people over emphasize
one aspect of dependability at the
expense of others and ended up with an
unsatisfactory solution and talk a bit
about yeah what is it that stinks
stakeholders are really depending on are
they depending on just safety or just
security or just accuracy or just
response to him and these things often
conflict so again what we'll talk about
is how do you determine how much
dependability is enough if you're trying
to compete with other companies on not
just dependability but time to market
and then the cost and price and things
like that
so the the business case basically says
if if you have a finite amount of
resources and Microsoft has more
resources than most companies but
they're still finite the investments and
dependability are competing for
resources with investments in features
and response time and adaptability and
speed of development and things like
that and each thing that you invest on
generates curves of yeah what's the
present value of the flows of benefits
you get from putting this much feature
functionality or this much dependability
in versus the cost of putting all out in
and you can discount that for present
value and compete compute returns on
investments and again what you find is
that the values of the benefits very
bike who you are and then what you're
responsible for so let's take an example
of suppose you are approached by a
vendor who says we've got the world's
best test data generator we've got a
track record of being able to cut
people's test cases in half what we'll
do is provide you with this marvelous
bargain we'll provide it to you for
thirty percent of your test costs so if
you're spending a million dollars will
give us to you for three hundred
thousand dollars after you run all the
tests for fifty percent of your original
cost it'll only cost you a half a
million so your two hundred thousand
dollars ahead so if a vendor King to you
with this proposition what sort of
concerns would you have about it and in
any thoughts
yeah one thing is yeah is this something
that's been working for business and
you're doing real-time control or been
doing things for inventory and you're
doing financial or things like that any
other say something sizzling I got it
yeah so again you know what what is it
that's getting tested here is it just
the nominal case or is it is it covering
the off nominal cases as well and that
sort of thing so there's nothing that's
really said anything about those kind of
things yeah suppose the world should
change tomorrow and test cases I need
tomorrow or different things I mean
yesterday
oh my god
mission yeah there there is you don't
really know how how well this thing
works incrementally so it can change
one percent of your code you have to go
back and we run all the tests or can it
figure out which ones have been affected
by the change and
oh I get the other there's those kind of
okay well those though cover a number of
things the one I'm going to focus on
today though is really that the test
data generators are our value neutral
the as our most current software
engineering technique so they assume
every defect is equally important most
requirements tools or object-oriented
methods assume that every requirement
every use case every object every defect
every test case and people important but
usually what you find is that twenty
percent of the test cases cover eighty
percent of the business value but that's
a risk and that you're trying to what do
these tests to avoid so here's an
example from one of the testing trade
journals if an organization that found
that they had 15 types of customers and
for each customer type after they did
the tests they're rough they're they're
defect that their complaint rate went
from twenty five percent down to ten
percent
and what they had been doing was
basically treating every customer is
equally important and generating value
at a linear pace but what they found was
that one type of customer was accounting
for fifty percent of their rub their
Billings and that if they focused on the
the most business important past the
first that they could generate a lot
more return on investment if you look at
this fundamentally yeah if you would
bought the test automated test data
generator you be three hundred thousand
dollars in the hole here it would take
you sixty percent of the tests to break
even and you'd end up with two hundred
thousand ahead if you did value based
testing up using an 8020 kind of
approach up after you get to about
thirty yup percent of the tests you hear
five hundred and eighty thousand dollars
ahead in terms of net net value so
so again there's a lot of benefits that
can come from doing value-based testing
another talent though is that in a lot
of cases there is no one-size-fits-all
definition of what value is the poor for
somebody doing customer billing accuracy
of billing and an avoidance of sending
the wrong bills of the wrong people and
things like that are important that in
other application safety is more
important or security year and that sort
of thing so there are a lot of different
attributes of the ability that you're
starting up a new product are important
to address again one of these like
performance tears down the response time
and resource consumption so it's it's
complicated from that standpoint it also
means it's more complicated because the
value attributes are scenario dependent
once worked on a project where the
client said we want five second response
time in normal daily operation and we
want two seconds response time in a
crisis well what happens in a crisis
people generate more transactions per
second maybe the transactions are more
complex and so so the things are going
to get slower rather than faster and
unless you do something else like
minimize the non-essential messages
Oracle and and the value attributes
often conflict oh it if you want the
safety and robustness and fault
tolerance so what you want to do is
spread data around so that if one thing
crashing you can recover it from
somewhere else
if you want security you don't want to
spread data around reducing your
increasing your vulnerability to
penetrations and things like that and if
you do a lot of fall colorants checking
and security checking or compromising
performance so again there's a lot of
trade-offs that make this talent a
problem one of the things that we've
been trying to do is to one of our
agendas is really value based software
engineering so what we're trying to do
is take some of the value neutral
approaches and come up with new
definitions of what is what does
reliability mean and things like that if
different people rely on on different
things and so this got us involved in
looking at who are the stakeholders in
it in a typical of software application
again some of the people are people that
are supplying information into the
system well make a purchase with your
credit card you're supplying the credit
card number
well qualify for something give them
your social security number and again
you're not doing anything else with the
system but something of yours are that
risk there are situations in which your
again not part of the pump customers hat
or the developer set but you are flying
on the plane that is being controlled or
air traffic control by somebody else in
software so you have a state community
there are people that do value-added
services like financial people that
collect various things until you would
stop to buy or that sort of thing there
are people that consume information
either for making decisions or playing
video games or whatever it happens to be
there people that control missions like
pilots or distribution
network managers or things like that and
then there are people down here that the
develop and acquiring administer thing
know this win-win negotiation system
that we have is something that we've
used on over a hundred projects and one
of the nice things about it is that it
electronically captures the wind
conditions that people put in about
things like their level of service
attributes or quality after usability
attributes and so we can analyze what
kind of stakeholders depend on what kind
of thing so this is a little bit of
messy but but fundamentally what you can
see is that among all of these different
stakeholders that we mentioned and all
these dependability attributes that that
we mentioned that there is no uniform
profile that says the I of it everybody
thinks privacy is important some people
feel it's really important and some
people don't care and so again there
there is really no one-size-fits-all
approach another thing that we we do
with this though is nowadays when people
are negotiating levels of service and
win-win agreements about how much safety
do we need how much security do we need
we provide this as sort of a starting
point so that they you know if you are
this kind of stakeholder you ought to be
concerned about the following thing
so again a stakeholder value definition
of what dependability is sort of
elaborates on the standard definition
that I should working group n4 came up
with that said dependability is
something that guarantees people that if
they are relying on various kind of user
services that they can depend on them
being there so again it's a vector of
attribute levels and priorities that
reflect what the success critical
stakeholders are depending on depending
on their utility functions which again
may vary across different scenario so if
you have a crisis scenario you're going
to get a different kind of performance
and importance of of getting a
particular response time then if you're
in a daily operation
so here's another example one of the
research projects that were part of is
the NASA high dependability computing
program which part of what I've been
discussing is that a year in the program
people said well dependability is the
middle name of this program but nobody's
defined what dependability is and we try
to do that so you know all the stuff
that I mentioned was an attempt to try
to come up with better ways to define
and then reason about the various
attributes of dependability but one of
the things that the Earth Observation
distributed information system found was
that the operators were being
incentivized on minimizing downtime the
users wanted fast response to queries
that if you want to know how fast the
corn is going to grow in this company
and Iowa you want to know it in time to
do something about it what was happening
was that they the operators were
optimizing availability but they were
doing it in a way that the users would
get too weak response times on one
number of their queries a lot of times
that was too late to do anything about
the corn or whatever else was being
observed on the earth that was important
so typically if you get a win-lose
situation the people in a losing
position tend to do something to
compensate for that that usually turns
into a lose-lose situation oh well what
the users did in this case was if they
thought there was something that we're
going to need two weeks from now they
would submit a whole bunch of queries
about it so that up
if they needed that they would be
getting an answer for it but ninety
percent of the things I asked for
weren't being getting used so the
operators were finding that the other
their workload was growing and coping
with it was not a fun thing to do so
again now what we've been trying to do
is has come up with value-based
definitions of reliability it says the
system provides reliability to the
exhibit the extent that it maximizes the
probability that the system will
provides stakeholder desired levels of
service so again what we try to do in
this when wind system is is ask people
what is the what is your desired level
of service but also what is your
acceptable level of service I'd like one
second response time but i'll settle for
four seconds or something like that so
what this gives people is sort of a
trade space and in response time and
security and then and and safety and the
like that they can operate within with
respect to a systems operational profile
and again one of the profiles is crisis
another one is normal day-to-day
operation and then so again you need to
say what what do you want it a crisis
and if it's better than what you want in
a normal day what are you going to do
with your workload to make that possible
what this implies is that the same
system will have different values for
reliability up across different
combinations of stakeholder priorities
and different operational profile again
the usual thing that you hear quoted is
the mean time between failures of our
system is 10,000 hours well what is what
does that mean again it usually means
that somebody has come up with some
one-size-fits-all definition of a
failure that's that says it's system
crashes and if it's a crash of offline
services versus online services that's
just as important if it's something that
can be instantly recovered from that's
just as important and again and in most
cases those are not equally important
and things that don't crash that give
you the wrong answer and things like
that are not counted so so again up what
we're trying to do is provide
counterpart definition so that people
can reason about things in a value-based
way as well as this sort of about your
neutral way
so let's sort of summarize where we've
gotten too from here that there there is
no Universal dependability metric like
availability or reliability to to
optimize that if you're going to achieve
it in a way that your system is going to
succeed you need to identify who are the
success critical stakeholders and what
are their priorities so again some of
them are these users that want fast
response time and you neglect those
you're going to end up with a system
that it generates a bunch of unnecessary
workload you need to balance
satisfaction of stakeholder dependent
dependency so again what we find is that
doing stakeholder when when negotiation
is one way of doing this another way is
to do various kinds of trade-off
analyses between reliability and costs
and then schedule and response time and
things like that and so one of the
things that means is that you'd like to
have some value of dependability models
methods and tools so i'll show some
things that we've been doing in that
area
in front of this in some way there we go
ok so we've talked about the the
business case for software dependability
we've talked about what our stakeholders
really depending on now let's talk about
yeah what what does software inability
mean if you're in the marketplace
competing with a bunch of people
offering similar services is market
success a a monotone function of
dependability that the more dependable
it is the more money you make is quality
really free the classic book by Philip
Crosby call quality is free that def
conditioned a lot of people to assume
that everything they did in quality was
was not going to add to their bottom
line oh is faster better cheaper really
achievable again we were doing this
research for NASA which believed in
faster better cheaper and ended up with
a couple of Mars missions that cracked
and and that they were doing it faster
and cheaper but not necessarily better
and again looking at value-based versus
that neutral method
so I here is a a an interesting curve
that comes out of some work that Michael
Porter was Harvard Business School and
has written a couple of classic books
called competitive advantage and
competitive strategy and the competitive
advantage of nations up and up when I
was at tier w one of the things that
they had a student is to go to Michael
Porter school and learning out of how do
what how to reason about things like
costs and quality and what he had was a
curve that really sort of covered the
middle of this that fundamentally said
that for most kind of products you had a
choice of being the cost leader and in
delivering acceptable quality and
basically competing in the cost cost
constrained part of the marketplace or
you could go for the high quality part
of the market where people were less
concerned about cost but wanted the
thing prw at the time was over here it
was building all sorts of ultra-reliable
satellites and things like that and
people were saying well yeah we need to
compete with the with with the the lower
cost people in our market sector so why
don't we just reduce our quality a bit
and increase and reduce our costs a
little bit and what Michael Porter said
is that there's a place in the middle
here that you're not to keep enough to
compete with these people and they will
wipe you out and then you've lost your
ability to compete on the high quality
sector and so
and a lot of market sectors that that
shape is true and and again if you try
to make it to keep up basically people
will throw up when they they see your
thing and go off and buy something else
and if you're too high quality then you
get so overpriced that the very few
people can afford to buy what you're
what you're selling so one of the things
that we've been doing is coming up with
approaches of using risk to determine
how much is enough of doing testing or
doing formal methods or or doing
requirements traceability or cots
evaluation or things like that oh and
basically what this involves is their
reasoning about risk exposure which is
basically the probability of incurring
some kind of lost times the size of the
loss again the loss could be financial
it could be reputation that could be
future prospects and things like that
most of these tend to be more or less
independent so these are expected values
and you can add them up up into an
overall risk exposure oh
so gossip owes that you're saying up
we're trying to figure out how much
testing that is enough when should we
freeze the product and start rolling out
the machinery to produce 50 million
boxes or things like that and up so the
lawsuit unacceptable dependability says
that if you try to ship too soon you're
going to have a lot of defects though
your probability of loss is high and a
good many of them are going to be
critical so the size is high if you
continue to test and again if you do
value based testing you you can avoid
doing getting linear gains here but you
can get a t20 kind of games eventually
you get down here where there's few
defects and low probability of loss and
they're minor so there's a low size of
loss but it's taking you a long time to
get there so so there's this other thing
that says yeah what's our loss due to
market care erosion took us a year to
get here up and in that year three other
people introduced competitive products
and and there's only twenty percent of
the market size available to capture at
this point then you've gone from a
situation where shipping early is you've
got few rivals and then they don't have
very good products to a situation where
you go a lot of rivals and then they're
already very strong in the marketplace
so again means these risks add together
so
if you sum the risk exposures you get
this curve here that basically has a
sweet spot which is the a good operating
point for how much testing is enough for
this particular kind of buff of product
situation if you're building a safety
critical system typically what happens
is that defects are going to cause loss
of life and health and big recalls and
big lawsuits and then things like that
and so the size of loss due to defects
goes up and so the sum of that curve
plus the market care curve moves up and
then to the right he says that yeah how
much testing is enough for this kind of
company is much more important on the
other hand if you're an internet startup
the biggest source of loss is is delays
in the marketplace and again you can
afford to ship something that's that's
less dependable early up and again the
sweet spot moves over to the left and in
this particular case
one of the things that internet startups
sometimes forget is that they're they're
not going to stay startups all the time
at once they have built up a customer
base and things like that people are
going to be more concerned about quality
and things like that and this other
curve is going to start moving up and
requiring them to move in to the right
in terms of quality or how much testing
is enough one thing you'll notice yeah
what are the units and dimensions run
yeah well they are typically dollars or
expected dollars and months so over here
but you'll notice there's no scales on
these and so later on I'll show some
more quantitative things that we've done
with the Kokomo model that enable you to
put actual numbers in there if you were
a monopoly you should never shoot ah
Reba love me yeah yeah so
there's unwise to try to compete on both
cost schedule equality some exception
acceptance major technology or
marketplace at so yeah by if you have a
monopoly then you can move along that
the dependability segment with a lot
more to freedom and somebody that it has
a lot of people competitors that they're
competing with well in some parts of
Microsoft product line there there's a
lot more freedom than others
oh and again so that says there's no
one-size-fits-all costs Kendall quality
strat strategy so your strategy for
Windows is going to be a little bit
different than the strategy for you to
search engine or the poor things like
that risk analysis is something that
that helps determine how much is enough
of things like a prototyping should be
do I'm not formal verification on the
cops evaluation things like that so and
how much documentation should you do
what's the risk of doing more and then
what's the risk of doing less and then
typically you can find some sweet spot
in the middle that duct that gives you a
good operating point for how much of
this is enough another thing you can do
if you're not sure about that it is to
buy information and say oh well if we're
not a doer just how this search
algorithm has been scale up but we spend
a lot of time prototyping do to verify
that it's going to scale up but before
we commit to it
and again it's often difficult to
determine these parameter values in some
cases a lot of companies have found that
they can do quite well in just getting
consensus on a scale of 1 to 10 of
what's the relative risk and the
relative loss and help that those
determine priorities from that there are
a number of things that the construction
cost model version 2 can can help do
it's a a model that is calibrated to 161
projects that cover things that computer
companies and software companies and
narrow space companies have have done
and each one of these projects rated
itself on whether it's required
reliability was very low and in that the
effect of a defect was a slight
convenience or that which basically
was equivalent to a rough mean time
between failure of about an hour or
something that was easy to recover from
so at the cracked once a day that was
okay or something that was a moderate
recoverable loss that there's something
in fact once a month was what it was
okay to high financial loss and loss of
human life so so again each of these
products calibrated themselves or that
rated themselves on the scale and we did
a data analysis and and a multiple
regression analysis to see how much of
the variance was accounted for by
applications experience and tool support
and process maturity and things like
that and for required reliability what
we found was that the the slope of this
curve was was about ten percent per
rough per his priest cost per level that
you were going up here so this is the
the net product of two trends that
I want one of the trends is that's gotta
more quality that you want the more
rigorous you need to be about the
requirements and the architecture and
the coding and the testing and things
like that and the more thoroughly you
need to invest in testing and so forth
on the other hand there there's another
trend that says the more rigorous you
are about requirements and architecture
the more defects you get out early when
they're keep the fix and so that that
tends to drive this cost down but the
matter of fact across the 161 projects
was this kind of slope it goes it gets a
little bit more expensive per line of
code going from commercial quality
leader to safety critical oh yeah what
this says is that if it provides a sort
of a
way of reasoning about how much it's
going to cost you to jump but this is a
costco source and stroke yeah this is
what I've seen more swords instructor to
be safety critical and recovered more
blueberries and hang underhanded
discussed into the break does another
Colgate figure will you want to get to
the high reliability yeah one of the
things that we are doing for the Federal
Aviation Administration right now is
building a computer security extension
to kokomo two and four security some of
some of the things that they are
requiring in terms of certification go
beyond what what some of the safety
things do oh and also for for all of the
security functions like encryption and
access control and intrusion detection
and all that sort of thing you're adding
more lines of code so so the the kokomo
to extension is addressing how much
bigger is the product getting and then
per line of code how much more expensive
as it getting yeah thanks for the
question any other questions on many of
this
okay uh so again you know what what does
that say about quality is free here is
something that says the more quality you
get the more expensive again and again
that this is frequently the case he used
to cite the the Japanese automotive
manufacturers as people that were
proving that would qualify why is it
that Alexis costs more than a Corolla or
something like that certain kinds of
quality do cost more even with Japanese
manufacturers but what you find is that
investments in dependable systems cost
extra oh all we were calibrating to was
development costs there so what's the
situation in life cycle costs that the
more buggy it is the more expensive it
is to maintain so and what is the if you
cost it include total costs of ownership
in terms of the cost of doing recalls
and paying off lawsuits and things like
that what happens so so it turns out
that if you have high value long life
systems quality does turn out to be free
if you're just building something to
keep track of your CDs or something like
that or you're building something that
is supporting a single decision that
you're going to make in a month later
after you've made the decision you're
never going to use that software again
then maintenance costs are not worth
worrying about so yeah here's this life
cycle cost versus dependability for the
relative cost to develop if you the
calibrated kokomo model for the
reliability variable for maintenance is
that over here building sloppy software
means that you've got interactions of
defects and a lot of things that cause
the cost per instruction to go up for
every instruction that you modify your
aunt
over here you get the net effect of two
things that you driven down the cost the
nineteen percent from where it was here
but you still got to run all those
regression tests to make sure that it's
safe to operate so again the net cost is
higher than the nominal there so if you
have a situation that the typical thing
I don't know what it is here for windows
which probably hard to tell because it
at any given time you're putting new
features in and so it's hard to say
what's development what's maintenance
but the typical organization spends
seventy percent of its life cycle
software costs doing maintenance so so
if you go seventy percent of the way
between here and here you find that
again building cheap software is not a
good thing to do if you look at total
cost of owning and operating the
software and including the effect on non
sales if the system goes down a lot
including effective lawsuits and that
sort of thing if you take one case in
which the operational defect cost is
roughly equal to the software lifecycle
costs a good example would be the Intel
Pentium chip that basically cost them a
half a billion dollars to develop and it
cost them a half a billion dollars to go
back and recall in and then
and so in that case that this curve says
that investing in a very high level of
required reliability is worth it
I'm gonna do to blame the pendejo well I
say vascular counting okay well now that
that's one of the things that is
difficult to do in software metrics you
try to figure out yet what were the
assumptions behind all of these numbers
that you get and that's that's a good
point but at any rate tough guy if the
the as your operational exposure gets
bigger and bigger the value of
investments and dependability gets
better and better
so let's let's look at a couple of other
things like guy is faster better cheaper
really achievable oh there there's a a
frequent slogan in in the software area
that and I guess probably in the
hardware area to that says if you want
cost schedule and quality pick any two
if you are building something that is
supposed to fit within this volume here
you can move this triangle upward to the
right or left and then get two of these
to fit inside the little circle but the
third one is going to be hanging up so
so anybody see a way to
get all three shrink the triangle right
now so well basically guy if this is the
cost schedule quality for building a
hundred thousand lines of code there's a
triangle for building 77,000 lines of
code at least kokomo that that fits
within the circle and so again what one
of the things that you can do is if if
these are your really independent
variables and you can't have features
that as an independent variable too and
so what you need to do is something that
for small systems is called time boxing
and for larger systems is something that
we call cost schedule and or quality as
independent variable and what it says is
that you need to determine your just how
much dependability is enough for your
particular market place do this and
desire delivery defect density or some
value based equivalent what you want to
make sure it is to go in and either work
with your users if that's the kind of
thing you're doing or your marketing
people to prioritize the desired
features and again there you can use
quality function deployment or
integrated product teams or stakeholder
when when to do that kind of thing
and one of the things that Kokomo gives
you these days is something that is a
most likely cost so what is the
probability that you'll exceed the most
likely cause
most likely means fifty percent so
percent of the time well uh outside but
in in reality if you generally
recognized that most initial cost
estimates forget about the derived
requirements and forget about
requirements creep and volatility and
things like that yeah the Standish
report currently says something like
seventy two percent or something like
that but don't get coming in on budget
is gentle and even then the ones that
came in within budget and schedule
frequently deliver only sixty percent of
the features that they originally
invited to deliver so under it is
probably a better estimate
at any rate assuming that the things are
relatively stable the Kokomo model gives
you an optimistic and a pessimistic
estimate and the pessimistic one says
you can build this many features or this
much this many lines of code within this
costume and schedule and again using
parametric model using expert judgment
as well is a good thing to do so one of
the things you want to do then is to
once you've prioritize the features is
to try to architect your system so that
it's easy to add and drop borderline
priority features and again some of the
things
David harness has come up with Anya
larity and information hiding are good
ways to do this
then you can develop a core capability
to this quality level and the core
capability again you've got a ninety
percent chance of making it so most of
the time you will end up with costume
schedule left over and you can add next
priority features as resources permit so
this is a model that we use on pretty
much all of the projects that we
currently billed as campus service
applications at USC are our software
engineering course as maintenance some
of the people who have taken it and
testify organizes people into five or
six person teams and puts them together
with somebody in the medical school who
is doing maternal child care
pathology slides or things like that or
the architecture in pineville of the
business school to build some kind of
system and take it from a two-paragraph
statement of goals down to requirements
architecture code testing and transition
all in 24 weeks and if the team sign up
for 48 weeks worth of work the end of 24
weeks they have a partially finished
product an unhappy customer and a low
grade so scheduled is very definitely an
independent variable in this case so all
of these teams have done this and only
two of them have failed and a couple of
them out of those two one was just an
irresponsible set of students who their
client went out of town and they decided
a more important interview for jobs and
the finished project
the other one with a cots product that
never got delivered on time so at any
rate now this this is a ninety-four
percent success rate which is a lot
better than the twenty-eight percent
success rate in the Standish Group party
or zero percent how r 0 cos n yeah
that's right so it turns out that
besides this required reliability cost
driver Kokomo also has a schedule
compression cost driver that says the
shorter you try to make the schedule the
more expensive it gets per line of code
so it provides you with a set of
trade-off curves for doing this balance
of cost schedule and quality so suppose
you have a situation in which you need
something developed in in 20 months to
meet some kind of event
and you have a budget of five and a half
million dollars and you want it to have
a 10,000 hour mean time between gear
what you find is that if you want all
three of if you want 10,000 any time
between failure in 20 months it's going
to cost me seven and a half million
dollars if you want to only pay 75 and a
half million then you've gotta settle
for low quality of 10 our kind of
behavior or if you want dup Causton and
quality you've got to allow it to take
24 months rather than 20 months so so
again trying to get all three is
difficult if you're insisting on a
hundred thousand line piece of software
on the other hand as i mentioned if you
go down to seventy seven thousand lines
of features then you can get this point
here with with the right budget the
right schedule and and the right quality
so that stuff any questions on any of
any of those things how much time did I
okay oh yeah I'll jump over a couple of
things and then just focus on a couple
others if dumb so uh yeah let's talk
about some more things like up we like
guv basically we have a model that
uses the kokomo inputs of applications
experience and architecture and dual
support and things like that and
estimates the
time between failure or deliver defect
density of a system
and I'll talk about that and then show
how we can use Kokomo & Co Cuomo and a
value estimating relationship approach
to come up with return on investment for
investments in dependability so this
week so the constructive quality model
fundamentally says what what the cost
model kokomo to does is asked for you to
tell it how big is the software you're
going to produce what are
characteristics of the platform has it
got all the memory and execution cycle
with anybody ever need or is this
something that is got to fit on some
little tiny piece of smart dust with a
limited memory and execution cycle or
something like that or it's got to go
out at space and then it's got little
imitation
their power up volatile is the platform
project things like well support is is
the system by by software requirements
ruled architecture can you design tools
code to old test tools and that sort of
thing and product characteristics like
yeah how complex's it how big is the
database reusable does it have to be
like that and people attributes like
that what what is the turnover on the
team and what if the application is in
platform and language cool experience
and those words event so Kokomo to we'll
take these estimates and give you
software development costs and schedule
for whatever you put in for the required
reliability the Kokomo extension takes
all of those and says this gives you a
way of estimating how many defects are
going to be in
your system and
calibrated this model and the if you
have a pure vanilla project in terms of
all these attributes you will typically
insert ten requirements defects 20
design defects and 30 code defects per
thousand lines of code and
then if you're doing this project with
people that haven't done anything in
this domain before typically the number
of requirements defects is going to go
up considerably the line will go up some
and the code is going to be more or less
similar to may go up a little bit so the
defect introduction model adjusts these
nominal rates to give you a rate at
which you're introducing requirements
design and code defects in your product
and then there's a defect removal model
here that says how much are you
investing in automated tool that our
model checkers or requirements
traceability tools or rough architecture
analysis tools or code standards
compliance tools or rough deadlock can
race condition detectors or
things like that and how much are you
investing in people review the formal
inspections or informal inspections or
walkthroughs or a buddy checking or like
that and how much are you investing in
execution testing though it has some
scales at all I'll go and based on how
much you invest in these it estimates
how much it's going to how many of the
defects you're going to remove so so
again automated analysis starts over
here very low is is it early doing
nothing here you're taking what the
compiler tells you is wrong with the
syntax and everything else you you're
going to wait until we test it to get it
but again if you've got a number of
things that do more powerful compiler
capabilities or compiler extensions that
do semantics checking basic things that
are doing consistency checking of the
requirements and design or doing module
level of effects of whether the code is
consistent with the requirements in the
design in various ways or you're doing
formal specification verification and
roll objects or things like that stuff
again the more you do of this the Moores
cost for one thing but the more defects
you're going to get out the more peer
reviews if you don't do anything then
all of those defects are going to that
we're introduced or just going to stay
there and the more you go into extensive
review kick bless and statistical
process control the better you can do
and again if you don't do any testing
the defects are going to stay there but
if you do a lot of testing with with
highly advanced tools and model-based
testing and that sort of thing then not
a lot of the effective
speaks to the value of the defects that
you find in
particular scale is it just numbered uh
that's a very good question and
fundamentally after reaching to you
about database testing Here I am showing
you a tool that that is being bad
neutral about those and again we are
working on an extension of this model
that is going to do more value based
approaches so one of the things that
we've introduced into our software
engineering course this year is an
experiment were last year basically the
checklist of people used in reviews were
value neutral every effectively
important and then this time we've but
said that yahweh we're doing high medium
low priority and having the clients
prioritize all the features and levels
of service and things like that and then
each source of defects whether it's a
misspelled help
or a pager to backup and recovery now
prioritize the criticality of the defect
so half the team is losing half the
teams are using the old method and half
of our using the new method then and
we're going to see how much value added
this value based checklists provide
and again here here we are with every
defect is considered equally important
that the
numbers that we've calibrated the the
model to indicate that basically you get
a factor of about 40 going from letting
Albany hex go through and two
significant investments and again you
can get another factor of 40 or 100 in
some cases and kings of defect
prevention and getting the 60 down to
something like one
so we use the Kokomo model to ID a
stands for information dependability
after you Xandra and what it says is
that you put your information processing
capabilities into a model that says yeah
how big are the features and you know
how complex are they and things like
that and Kokomo gives you a cost
estimate for that with copal mo you put
in a a set of time phase dependability
investments and it tells you how much
those are going to cost and it also
tells you what how how many defects
you're going to get out or what's
happened here
failures and availability like that and
then you up get the plants to determine
yeah what is the effect on on your
business if you have one percent versus
five percent downtime or things like
that that is something so you get the
cost you get the capable dependability
and you get the value of dependability
and then and that gives you a way of
thing what are the benefits and what are
the costs of getting any turn on
investment so it turns out that
depending again on what kind of
stakeholder you are there are a lot of
different utility functions for various
things so take response time if you're
doing real-time control getting the
commands to the real-time controller
before the real time deadline means that
your value is is anytime before there is
equally good anytime after there is this
is equally worthless if you're doing
mission planning or competitive decision
making or things like that typically
there's a place where you're so far
ahead of the game that it doesn't hurt
to be slow a point where you're getting
into competitive situations where you
lay does have a big cost and then over
here you're so far behind your
competition that that waiting another
day
help you much there are some other
interesting ones that say as time goes
on your data gets better and so doing
weather prediction the closer you get
the time that you're predicting it the
better your prediction is on the other
hand after the weather has got here and
the weather prediction isn't worth much
software size is the same kind of thing
it makes it a lot better when you've
built it but after that to the Q number
there there are some things like archive
data in a library or digital library or
things like that that the loss is not
all that much and then there are things
where you have these left price levels
of service though if you want
gigabit ethernet you pay a certain
amount for that if you want dsl you pay
a certain amount for that if you want my
old telephone service is a different one
for that but you get slower response
similarly you can do things for
availability so the normal approach to
availability it is one of these s
conectate curves it says that if you're
really terrible unavailability then a
little bit of difference is going to
matter much so a good example dbase for
anybody know what debase for well there
was a company called ashton taped in
southern california and debase 3 was the
number two database management system in
the world and you pay for got shipped
year ahead of when the Quality Assurance
people said it should have been and it
was so buggy that they were in chapter
11 a year later so again a small amount
of of improvements and availability
wouldn't have made much difference there
we would have gone bankrupt anyway but
there is a point over here that the
incremental improvements in availability
are going to make a big difference and
then at some point hayloft but there was
some data that rich demillo gave it that
a couple of liability conferences that
you've gotten from some major companies
that said in
terms of their order processing systems
what was it costing them per hour of
downtime Noel said if we're down for an
hour it costs us two hundred and
seventy-five thousand dollars in profit
amazon.com 27k base at 3k again if you
cans on your volume it depends on how
sensitive your customers are with a mess
pliers or individual buyers and then
things like that
but any right you can come up with these
linear approximations that say for a lot
of organizations you can come up with a
cost per hour of downtime and then get a
reasonable value estimating relationship
for availability
so fundamentally what we what we've done
is to take the Kokomo models up
estimates of how much how much extra
does it cost you compared to the very
low to get increments in reliability and
typically the investments in peer
reviews and automated tools and to pay
for themselves and then the place that
the added cost usually comes is in the
added testing so basically going from
nominal to high is going to add twelve
percent to the VP of the amount of time
that you're going to take testing the
destination system the defect removal
rate that comes out of the constructive
quality model basically said that you
were going to
decrease the defect rate by a factor of
2 free level what improving things here
so fundamentally that the defect rate
more or less correlates with probability
of loss so so you can do that curve to
approximate probability of loss and for
various companies you can come up with a
curve of what's the size of losses as a
function of market care erosion and so
what we've done here is is put in one
for early startups one for commercial
and one for high finance that there are
factors of three bigger and what you can
see is that and
again there's a market risk curve that
goes that way that says as as the risk
the size of the loss goes up here that
the the sweet spot for how much testing
is enough goes up again you can use
these kind of models to help determine
how much time should you plan for
testing when you're doing the project
again you may find the requirements
grief and then and shifting deadlines
and them things like that may cause you
to revise that initial estimate but at
least you can get you in the right
ballpark at the beginning
um
again now that was assuming that you
were using value-based testing if you do
value neutral testing then you have a
flat line there and what happens the
sweet spot moves over and up and so it's
going to cost you about the period that
your risk exposure is going to go up
about forty percent by doing that
neutral difference again we've done
things like this for for NASA and in
various applications that say how much
the investment in and required
reliability is enough for various kinds
of software so if you're planning a
lunar biological laboratory up there are
some things that are mission critical
that the software is wrong it
contaminates the atmosphere in the
experiment and it is
lose their health of their lives there
are a number of things that are online
operational software and offline support
and putting numbers in this model
indicates that going from nominal to
high produces a positive return on
investment for offline support than a
negative 14 going from high to very high
online operational going from high very
high is a positive return on investment
but the negatives and something beyond
their and mission-critical means you
really want to do an extra high level of
dependability for that
again what this thing help you do it is
to determine what number you put in for
an availability requirement for
different parts of your application so
what these really NASA would serve what
number should we put in so we put four
9s or five nines or something like that
then this says that it get carried by
what kind of software you have and it
gives you an algorithm for determining
what is at least it with going in number
so again to conclude all of this now
there there is no Universal information
system dependability metric to optimize
who your stakeholders are what their
value propositions or wind conditions
are you get different answer there's an
increasing need for these kinds of
things that basically software is
getting more and more critical to
everything that everybody builds and so
building cars or radios and things like
that more and more of it is software and
determining how much dependability is is
enough for the entertainment part of the
system and the real-time control part of
the system motor-car are really
important you can use risk analysis to
determine how much the information
system uses is enough what testing is
enough from a documentation architecture
analysis
quality is free in a number of cases
generally if you have a stable system
that has a lot of value at risk if it
fails and it's going to be around for a
long time but not then if you have
something that is going to be obsolete
next week has less at risk and is not
going to be used very long and again
what I'm sure you're finding here is
that the kind of systems that your
software is going to be supporting it in
the future are are getting more critical
they're getting more complex they're
becoming systems and systems that
originally built stove pipes need to
interoperate with each other and things
like that in your case you don't have a
lot of the problems that most people
have and that they're depending on cots
products that that they can't see and
they can't determine the evolution of in
your case you're building most of these
so you still have control over those but
the technology is changing faster the
marketplaces changing pad
consumers interests are changing faster
and like that so there's a lot of be to
balance discipline and ability with the
subject of a different talk in a
different book
have time to get into so and any little
question that was all we have
union organization like Microsoft that
we've got a lot of different quality
practices we can adopt if you look
across the whole company gosh you know
you've got everything here somewhere
Microsoft to get people doing anything
the problem we have is we were not able
to be reflective on how successful or
how well we're doing because we're not
gathering these metrics we kind of eli
could look at kokomo when we say okay
well these are good general guidance but
I can't really decide whether to adopt
this particular Microsoft tool and
invest the time or not what are you
seeing is the adoption rate and the
barriers to adoption two companies
spending the time to really collect like
Anna Kokomo quality
okay here again it it varies a lot and
very hot within companies
at one point in the late 80s their their
CEO said how r we're great on hard work
quality and were terrible on software
quality and they they they got they put
software quality and defect rates and
into every division general managers
bonus criteria and they got people like
Bob Brady to do a corporate-wide metrics
effort and and again you know they they
use this purpose approach of
functionality usability reliabilities
Portability and so forth enough so they
they decrease their defect rate by a
factor of ten and in five years then any
CEO showed up and up and it's started
degrading and the stove pipes market the
pressures decreased their their their
dependability
they brought rich mellow and to try to
fix that and then they quite compact and
he emphasized it and so a lot of
companies sort of go up and down and how
they do this but yeah
you a factor too they've done a really
good job at times if IBM does a very
good job of the orthogonal defect
classification and that kind of thing it
can really do keep the metrics and they
can tell you how many of the defects of
logic and algorithms and interfaces and
timing and things like that are likely
to show up that each phase gate and if
you've got too many or too little you
ought to take another look at what's
happening in your process large now what
am I called metrics happy gaming and on
your earlier your opening statements
about how methods could go wrong I
thought only got the tip of the iceberg
and it was sort of assuming that
everyone's well-meaning and working
together but of course that's almost
never the case and the presupposition
and it's more important in your case
you're just trying to predict future
defects but a lot of these metrics are
used to run operations and and now
they're getting baked into outsourcing
ingredients so you know the outsourcing
group is has to keep the metrics above
certain bar and then they can cut price
as much as they can to get it they get
to eat the prop
this is 0 then you get into this
interesting gaming of the metrics the
metrics are all supposed to appear to be
meaningful but actually not all right so
for example availability is a good one
the system is always up except when it's
reported to be down yeah we're not
allowed to report that it's down yeah
and as long as we don't have a mechanism
or there's a defect than that reporting
mechanism then we're always up yeah I'm
right okay um and what I what I think is
going on here is that this gaming of the
metrics now in this sort of newfangled
internet adversarial rangement is
actually taking over the well intentions
of this in and I would think that if the
metrics are sufficiently what we call
mindless metrics um then all of this is
moving yeah yeah
how much metrics is enough was a list of
doing too much and little and now what
wrong one Barry Weinberg had a great
story about I am used to give a zero
defect award for the product with the
least number of defects one here the
winner of this only had one defect
oh the other could help one of the
challenges in an organization like
Microsoft where we got rate of
technology change its internal
development technology and sunnyside
process changes extremely high formatted
by the
we have enormous and problems
establishing
some of the changes find out changing is
very fundamental assumption things it's
post that
reported back
see all these crashes getting report
back allows increased focus on me they
say that the defense that caused the
most crashes in the field this one's of
meaning that defect density ceases to be
anywhere near is accurate and a
predictor
most users experience at the mean time
between failure and we have a very
difficult time knowing how they have an
established base line sir I need any
thoughts or directions of might consider
looking at well yeah I here again yeah I
think there are a number of things that
again you need to work on you know how
much is enough would like to sort of
contextualized the data what context was
was
they gathered and
in some cases you can do
instruction testing and branch testing
and things like that and up and start
driving your defect rate way down all of
a sudden if you do scenario based
testing it goes up against me but you're
doing a different operational profile it
goes down and you do monkey testing it
goes up for that kind of thing something
so what you would like in is some way of
contextualizing things and again people
have come up with 40 context variables
and again you've got to say how many
contacts very bold enough and the
problem is we wind up with more context
variables their data rates yeah right
you can get everything so so well yeah I
am hoping we can get together on some of
this we had one of our PhD students work
at Cambridge this
trying to analyze some of the code turn
vs defect rate sings in windows and
we're kind of do some kind of follow up
and continue that kind of thing we would
really like to do that
okay hell is this work published in
matters of butcher paper Stinson ah i
can give you the current draft of the
report that yeah fundamentally it will
have n captors and made of them are
written them and we're trying to get the
last ones but yeah i'd be happy to send
you what we have
you can throw out any
comments about really good or really bad
about turning a Valentine software
process you know as a framework for
gathering and provide gathering metrics
and revising process ah yeah I would
love to talk to anybody who's part of
that here and I think you're a good
independent test and how that works but
I here again what what you find is that
it is something that is still being
validated as far as
as sort of the distance from the
originator effect what people found this
Harlan mills's cleanroom approach was
that if you were one person different
from Harlem Mills leaning worked really
well if you were three people distant
from Harlan Mills it didn't work so well
and I think there's a similar thing with
with wats Humphrey your uber Davis and
really understand and really know how to
cut corners on all of this heavyweight
stuff that's in the guidelines and tech
lists and the role then then you can
make it work quite well on the other
hand if you pick up the book again
you're going to get into this metrics
overkill process over build
people just can't keep it balanced or
something
I don't know why right but they lose
sight that they're here to ship a proper
focus becomes on doing tsp
scenario based on whatever it is right
and have you run into people that have
done a good job at trying to maintain
the balance and these kind of systems
yeah wait we have a book out that is
called balancing agility and discipline
basically about four years ago we
started looking into agile methods and
saying oh there there is something here
that we ought to evaluate them and our
affiliates again note that this was an
important area that they'd like some
illumination on and fundamentally yeah
we don't want to you know our guidelines
for doing these courses on campus are
deliberately over killed because we want
the students to learn industrial best
practices but having a free
page set of guidelines to do a small
project is is too much and so we wanted
to see what what could we do to what
what's good about these agile methods
that balance all this heavy
documentation and again what what we
found was that the risk is a pretty good
way of determining how much process is
enough in some cases if your safety
critical or that sort of thing a lot of
process is important
on a panel that reviewed the sources of
crashes in ballistic missiles and
basically the the main source of King
was item four in the aipean and
manifesto that says we prefer responding
obtained over following implant people
would respond to change and say I'm
going to put this patch in there and
they would not follow the configuration
management plans or quality assurance or
regression test plans and the missile
with crash so again the risk exposure is
sort of Yama how much is at stake if you
don't follow the plan if you're doing a
a
please sprint to deliver
incremental business capability and if
it's wrong you can fix it in the next
monthly spirit then that's not cracking
the missile and then it can be much more
less focused on heavyweight processes of
documents and stuff like that
this brings up a question I had since
about your first slide which where you
show the handcrafted test versus the
automatic test generation and the
automatic test generation giving that a
neutral tests but I would never use
automated test generation that way and I
don't think anybody would they would
take it and use it to generate tests in
the area or aiming that test generation
them people okay that's awful can you
use the assistance to so you know should
I be reading your next book then on
balancing the two because I don't know
anybody who would either well I I know
people would handcraft their tests no
and I but I think they're a minority now
and the test generation value-neutral
very few people would do how do you how
do you guide between those choices uh
well if ya hear here again I think yeah
yeah you try to point out being here the
costs of benefits of e
and and again try to avoid
one-size-fits-all solutions would say
I'm going to do the same thing for all
every piece of my software and it's like
that and so up
got here here again that's sort of what
we're trying to do incremental e as we
revamp the process research that we're
doing so what we're doing reviews say
don't just start on page one and then
read every every sentence equally
important but yea high priority
requirements first for the high quality
use cases first and and look for the
high criticality defects in it first and
then
okay good very much